this is the latest vessel being deployed
in the search for the Titan submersible
lost in the Atlantic Ocean since Sunday
the french-made Victor is a remotely
operated vehicle or ROV that can reach
depths of up to 6 000 meters it's hoped
the Victor can finally provide a
breakthrough in a search that has so far
produced no concrete results the U.S
Coast Guard leading the search and
rescue is stepping up its efforts we
currently have five service assets
searching for the Titan and we expect 10
Total Service assets to search in the
next 24 to 48 hours
there are two rovs actively searching
and several more are in route and will
arrive by tomorrow morning the Coast
Guard confirming that a Canadian
airplane heard banging noises from the
ocean both Tuesday night and Wednesday
morning noises that could be distressed
signals coming from the missing
submersible but when the Coast Guard
sent ships to the area they found
nothing listen you I think you need to
be careful
um
we need to have hope right but but I
don't I can't tell you what the noises
are but what I can tell you is and I
think this is the most important point
we're searching where the noises are and
that's all we can do at this point
however even if they find the Titan it
would only be the start of any potential
rescue well uh on the depths of 4 000
meters everything is very difficult even
the rescue you don't have any standard
procedures you know
um at these steps because it's a very
unusual situation
the Coast Guard estimates the reserve
breathable oxygen on the Titan will run
out by sometime Thursday morning local
time even so if the five passengers
aboard are still alive their chances of
successful rescue are diminishing by the
hour
Gabriel ozando Al Jazeera Boston